لعقود تم تحجين قدرات الجيش الالماني منذ
هزيمته في الحرب العالميه الثانيه لكن بعد
اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا اعلن برلين عن
خطه جديده لاعاده هيكله الجيش وتطويره هذا
عبر رصد مئه مليار يورو لهذه الخطه ورغم
مرور اكثر من عام على الحرب في اوكرانيا
هناك تشكيك فعلي في اي خطوات ملموسه تم
تحقيقها على الارض وكذلك اي خطوات تم
اتباعها لتحقيق هذه الاستراتيجيه للوقوف
اكثر على تفاصيل الخطه الالمانيه وكذلك
مستقبلها ينضم الينا الدكتور كريستيان مول
نائب مدير المجلس الالماني للعلاقات
الخارجيه اولا دكتور كريستيان اهلا بك
معنا في عسكري تاريا يعني برغم مرور قرابه
العام تقريبا على الخطه التي اعلن عنها
المستشارت بشان تطوير الجيش هناك من يرى
بانه لم يحدث اي شيء على ارض الواقع هل
تتفق مع هذا الامر ان هناك خطوات اخرى لم
يتم الاعلان عنها ربما
يمكن القول انه لا شيء تحقق على الارض ولم
نستلم شيئا مقابل المائه مليار الا اننا
نعرف في المانيا وفي اغلب انحاء اوروبا
لان المشتريات العامه وفي قطاع الدفاع
بشكل خاص تستغرق فتره طويله لقد قدمت
طلبات لشراء طائرات مقاتله وطائرات نقل
كبيره وهي في طريقها للتسليم ولكننا لا
نتوقع استلامها الان ولا حتى في العام
القادم بل ربما بين عامي
2028 كما يحق القول ايضا ان هناك اموالا
طائله متبقيه يجب ان تنفق بسرعه لان
قواتنا المسلحه في وضع سيء للغايه
الدكتور كريستيان الامر لا يتعلق فقط
بالاسلحه هناك بعض التقارير التي رصدت
بانه الجيش الالماني عان على مدى عقود من
انطباع سيء خلفته الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بل وحتى هناك احجام من قبل الشباب في
الانضمام للجيش هل ما زالت هذه الازمه
موجوده وهل بالفعل ما زال الشباب الالماني
لا يرغبون في الانضمام للجيش ام لا
نعم هذا صحيح الجيش لا يعاني فقط من نقص
المواد بل قطاع الدفاع باكمله يعاني طوال
30 عاما مضت من قله الانفاق على القوات
المسلحه ونحن نعيش في حلقه مفرغه لان
معدات الجيش اصبحت باليه كما ان الاستثمار
في الستوكينات العسكريه على سبيل المثال
غير كاف ولم يعد الجميع يرغب بالعمل مع
الجيش لان اسلوب الانضمام الى الجيش تغير
ولم يعد يوفروا المحفزات التي تشجع الشباب
على الانضمام الى الجيش والخدمه فيه
لسنوات طويله وبالتالي فعل الجيش ان ينفق
اموالا كثيره قبل ان حسن الاوضاع وقبل ان
تتمكن القوات المسلحه من جذب الشباب
للانضمام اليها
الدكتور كريستيان كل دوله في حلف الناتو
لها اولويات في مساله التسلح برايك ما هي
الامور التي يجب ان تركز عليها المانيا في
هذه الخطه التي تتحدث عنها بشان تطوير
الجيش وكذلك اولويات التسلح والقطاعات
التي يجب الاهتمام بها
علينا ان نتذكر ان المانيا التزمت بشكل
كبير تجاه النيتو عبر الطائرات المقاتله
والدفاع الجوي وكذلك قدرات الدفاع البريه
وكل هذه الامور غير متوفره منذ عام 2014
فالهدف من المئه مليار هو توفير هذه
الامور كما ان هناك مشكله اخرى تكمن في
جعل القوات المسلحه قادره على اتمام
مهامها اليوميه مثل وقطع الغيار الضروريه
وكل هذه الامور غير متوفره ايضا في الوقت
الذي تمثل فيه الاولويات الحقيقيه وليس
منظومه سلاح او اخرى بل تحديث القوات
المسلحه باكملها في اسرع وقت ممكن لان
المشكلات منتشره على جميع الاصعده حيث
اهملت قواتنا المسلحه منذ فتره طويله جدا
والجميع يواجه الضغوط الان لتحديث الجيش
وكما قلت فان المساله لا تخص منظومه سلاح
معين بل كبار اصحاب القرار في القوات
المسلحه وكذلك الوزير الذي قد يتغير قريبا
لقد اجريت عده تغييرات منذ فتره وهذه
التغييرات ربما تستمر من اجل بث الروح
المناسبه في هذه البيروقراطيه ودفع العجله
الى الامام دكتور كريستيان الرئيس الفرنسي
مانويل ماكرو تحدث مؤخرا ودعا الى عد
للقرار الامريكي فيما يتعلق بالصين تحديدا
هل تتفق برلين مع باريس في بشان هذه
الرؤيه الفرنسيه مؤخرا
فيما يخص ما قاله ماكرون فالامر يعتمد على
قراءه كل شخص لكلماته فربما يفهم من كلامه
انه موقف مشترك او ان كلامه يمثل اهانه
صحيح لا يجب ان يكون اي احد تابعا لامريكا
ويقوم بنفس ما تقوم به امريكا ولكن ما
يلمح اليه ماكرون وهو النسخه الفرنسيه
التي لا تتوافق معها اغلب الدول في النيتو
لا المانيا ولا دول وسط وشرق اوروبا بشكل
خاص ونشمالها فبالنسبه لهم امريكا هي
الضامن الامني خاصه تحت الظروف التي
نشهدها حاليا مع الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا وكذلك فيما يخص الصين فان جميع
يثق في امريكا لان باريس لم توفر البديل
المستشار الالماني دعم مؤخرا الى ضروره
توحيد الصناعات الدفاعيه الاوروبيه
لمواجهه الازمه سواء فيما يتعلق بنقص
الذخائر والاسلحه او كذلك للاعتماد بشكل
اكبر داخل القاره الاوروبيه وتوحيد القرار
الاوروبي في هذا المجال هل تعتقد بان مثل
هذه الافكار قابله للتطبيق على ارض الواقع
نظريا نعم ولكن على ارض الواقع هذه نبره
فلكلوريه نسمعها من كل مستشار الماني وكل
وزير دفاع وشؤون خارجيه المانيا لم تنفذ
ابدا ما وعدت به فيما يخص هذه المسائل
فالالتزام بالوعود لم يكن ابدا من نقاط
قوه المانيا ولا نعرف اذا ما كان المستشار
الحالي سيكون مختلفا لا يزال يقود حكومته
الاولى
ومع ذلك فهو قادر على تحقيق الفارق ولكن
هذا يتطلب منه العوده الى المئه مليار
والتعرف على المشروعات التي صمم من اجلها
هذا المبلغ والتي يمكن ان تستخدم للمبادره
في اطلاق مشروع اوروبي لان المشروعات
الاوروبيه لا تولد من الخطابات ولا
الاعلانات بل من الاموال والمشروعات التي
نطرحها امام الشركائنا ونسالهم ان كانوا
يرغبون بالانضمام اليها هذه المشروعات في
حاجه الى اموال طائله وفقط بعد انفاق كل
هذه الاموال نستطيع التحدث عنها